[Music]
bigquery is a fully managed cloud data
warehouse that provides incredibly fast
sequel analytics over large data sets
you can write and run queries directly
in the bigquery web UI in this video you
will learn how to use the bigquery UI to
run a query you will query the USA named
data public data set to determine the
most common names in the u.s. between
1910 and 2013 this same process can be
used to query other public data sets
available through the program your own
data sets or any other data set to which
you have the right permissions get
started by navigating to the bigquery UI
at console cloud google.com slash
bigquery if you are new to bigquery use
the video linked in the description
below to set up a new project in the
bigquery sandbox no credit card is
required if you are already a big query
or Google cloud platform user you may
select an existing project you will then
land in the query editor where you can
write and run sequel queries directly if
the query editor is not currently
displayed click compose new query at the
top right of the window to summon the
editor before writing a query you'll
start by navigating to the USA names
public data set in the resources section
of the left-hand nav click add data and
pin a project type bigquery public data
separated by dashes and click pen this
project contains several public data
sets expand the project and scroll down
and expand the USA names data set click
on the 1910 to current table where you
can review the table schema the schema
outlines the structure of the table and
provides a list of the columns available
to query here you can also view the
table details and preview the data click
query table in a pre-loaded query
statement will appear in the query
editor which you can begin editing
directly for this QuickStart
instead of editing the query copy and
paste the query text provided in the
video description below into the query
editor and then click the green check
mark on the right hand side of the
window to view the query validator
a green checkmark icon is displayed if
the query is valid if the query is
invalid a red exclamation point icon is
displayed the validator also shows the
amount of data the query will process
when you run it now click run the query
results page displays below the query
window at the top of the query results
page the time elapsed and the data
processed by the query are displayed
below you'll see a table displaying the
query results with a header row
containing the name of each column you
selected in the query you may now choose
to save the query to be accessed and run
at a later time
you may also save the query results in
one of several formats for further
analysis or follow the direct link to
explore the results in data studio happy
analyzing
[Music]